Welcome everybody to the h podcast
experience.
You guys know that today's episode is
sponsored by Ring Quip and me on Ds.
We have got so many great things today.
I don't hear the music because the music
play.
Oh yeah,
great,
great.
Today we've got such wonderful things.
We've got Logan Paul tweet of the
century erased and reborn.
We've got Roseanne finally speaking out.
And boy,
you don't want to miss this.
So good.
We have got other and lots of stuff.
We've got another episode of know your
meme given away a brand new s nine plus.
What what?
Um,
this time featuring everybody's favorite
virgin skippy.
Actually we have a new call in number
two that I think is really suiting that.
I think everyone is going to really
enjoy it.
You can reach us for now and forevermore
at eight zero eight hot meme,
that's eight oh eight hot meme and e m e
as you all know.
So that's our permanent number.
Keep it handy.
Uh,
guys,
you can start ringing in now to play.
Know your meme after the break featuring
everyone's favorite virgin skippy ilos
back.
Thank God,
thank the gods she is.
It's a little too soon for her to hop in
front of the camera.
So she is uh,
and back right now she's here,
she's cracking whips.
She is making sure that everybody is
crossing their t's and dotting their i's
back there.
They're all in mortal fear of you right
now.
It's true.
No fucking around this time.
But we will be having a special episode
next week on Tuesday.
I think what it's just gonna be me and
Isla probably just like a 30 minute
little app where we can just kind of
talk,
bring her back,
get her back in,
see how she's doing.
And then on Thursday we've got dunky
video game donkey and Leah.
It'd be great.
Would that being said,
we've got so much to get to,
but first let's start with our goof of
the day.
I was trying to think of a name of a
last week,
goof of the day.
I like the idea when we do these top of
the weeks to start it every time with a
beautiful,
great little video that we're all going
to love goof of the day up first we've
got laughter yoga,
this video.
I'm very conflicted about this video
laughter yoga because,
well yeah,
I'll just show you.
It's like these people,
they all have these awful diseases and
their method of coping with it is by
manic laughing.
I get it.
Like I think it's a cool thing,
but it's like it's so eerie and strange.
I mean,
let me,
let's just start it off right here guys.
Here we go.
God bless.
[inaudible]
diagnosis and we're going to laugh
again.
Yeah,
and so you go around the room,
it's very powerful.
Now if you don't,
and we'll do it just with a few people
here just to get a flavor.
If anybody has a diagnosis they want to
share and laugh about that,
that'd be great.
And if you don't,
then what I've done is combine it with
the ha ha mantra,
which is you'll say your name and what
happened recently to you that normally
would really bum you out and share it
with us and we'll laugh at it.
So it's that whole psychology of,
you know,
turning lemons.
Oops.
Was it into lemonade?
Okay,
so you guys get it.
This lady,
by the way,
where do you get that Eric?
I think on face value it sounds nice,
but when you watch it it's like I just
don't buy the laughter.
It's like the saddest shit I've ever
seen.
Yeah.
So here's,
I'll,
and I always start and say,
here's how it looks.
So my name is Geeta.
The one thing that throws me off,
it makes me feel strange about this is
like why laughing after the name?
It makes it seem like they're just
clowning.
Yeah.
That was about trauma.
Like they laugh,
they laugh after they say the trauma,
but then like they're like,
hi,
my name's Ethan.
It's like,
it feels like you're getting clowned on,
you're going to see what I mean.
Okay.
I Dunno.
[inaudible]
your name for Christ's sake.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
all right,
something's not right.
And I was diagnosed with Parkinson's.
[inaudible].
Anybody else want to share
the idea?
It's a strange,
it's a strange thing,
you know?
Very strange.
I get it.
You know,
It's a nice wholesome thing and they're
trying to do here.
I just,
I dunno.
It's so eerie.
That's something so off about it.
You'll see it get,
it gets more obscene as they go along,
but I don't get the whole very good.
Very good.
Yay.
Like all of a sudden they're in
kindergarten and it goes where they lost
me to be honest.
Yeah,
you're kind of understand it.
But then when the weird like cult
chanting started it,
it got pretty creepy,
right?
Error.
Yes.
My name is dawn
don.
He took a shot.
You know,
he put his hand up in class.
My name is Don.
Why you got to goof while you got a
clown on poor don?
That's so weird.
Or they laugh at their name.
I recently acquired insulin dependent
diabetes.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Not to see it like them just laughing at
their misfortune.
They're not,
it just,
I don't,
I don't see them like embrace from my
perspective,
I just acquired insulin resistant
diabetes.
I Dunno.
I just sounds like they're clowning on
hysterical.
That's the funniest Shit
I've heard all day.
Yay.
Yes.
Hi,
my name is Vicky.
Yes sir.
Okay.
The one that got me,
I've got breast cancer.
Okay.
That's the funniest shit I've heard all
year.
This,
this woman's eyes really lit up on that
one.
She's like,
she's like,
oh fuck.
A more tragic to the more hilarious.
My name's Vicky and um,
I was,
I was stranded and had to eat my own son
to stay alive.
Okay.
It's like the more tragic,
the more hilarious,
hey,
yes.
I don't buy it.
I think I just don't buy it.
Like she's got the happy face earrings.
She's got the laughter Yoga.
She's all smiles.
But
okay.
There's like a real sadness,
you know what I mean?
It's like they're not acknowledged.
I Dunno.
What do I know?
Healthy?
No.
Yeah,
that's what I don't know.
I don't know.
Something about this seems so demented
and I don't want to goof on these people
because,
you know,
they're trying to cope with some
difficult stuff.
Just trying to an allen analyze how I
feel about it.
Let's see.
Maybe the next one is just like straight
up like,
you know,
my husband,
I'm Dan and I murdered my son.
Right.
And I ate his corpse.
Very good.
Yay.
Becca.
Okay.
Diagnosed with 19 years ago.
Oh name and
let her like,
they cut the,
kind of cut her off.
They did like an academy award on her.
That's,
she's like,
I was developed with Ms 19 years ago.
It's like,
all right,
bitch,
tone it down.
It's old news.
It's 19 years ago and who gives a shit?
It was also like,
I didn't give you permission to expand.
You have Ms.
Move on to the next person.
We're all fucking dying here.
Yeah.
My name is,
uh,
hi guys.
My name is Ethan and um,
my anal sphincter muscle has stopped
operating and I'm perpetually shitting
my pants.
That's really nice.
That tragic compared to what they're
dealing with.
What's,
you know.
Okay.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Uh,
yes.
My name is Christine.
That's what people think.
I'm overweight.
Oh,
whoa,
whoa.
What was that?
Let me go back.
Got Up.
Does that got a huge laugh?
It wasn't just that she's okay.
Yay.
Yes.
My name is Christine.
Some people think I'm overweight.
Do you need to leave?
That doesn't qualify for Yoga.
Laughter.
By the way,
she wasn't like,
Oh,
I'm overweight.
I'm morbidly overweight.
She's like,
some people think the way people get the
fuck
bill and you got crickets.
We got breast cancer,
we got ms overweight.
Shut the fuck up.
Great.
I'm a little overweight.
Damn.
Wouldn't be great if she was just like,
you know what?
Stop everyone.
Stop laughing,
bitch.
Get Out.
[inaudible]
actually laughing now.
She's like,
this isn't laugh yoga.
I'm laughing at you.
Oh,
why would you need a group?
Council did cause your,
some people think you're overweight.
That's great.
I have arthritis and diabetes.
Arthritis and diabetes.
Give it up.
Yes.
My name's Jim.
Sometimes I get really scared about
running out of money.
You,
you,
you were.
You're in a different room.
Sometimes you get scared of running out
of money.
You and the fat lady need to go start
your own laughter yoga.
Okay.
What,
what?
They don't need to worry,
but you and everybody,
dude.
Huh?
All right.
I'm a chuckle at best.
Eh,
you don't deserve the laugh.
If I'm being frank chuckle yoga anyway,
I'm not sure how to make of all this
stuff.
It's like,
I know they're,
they're desperately trying to cope with
really awful,
unimaginable things,
but it's like,
it's just so eerie.
It's strange to see these things side by
side and I'm dying of breast cancer.
Ah,
yeah.
Anyway,
I have one other goof of the day that I
wanted to watch with you guys.
Uh,
the Pedo Lizard,
the day,
the,
it's goofs of the day today,
my friend.
Wow.
This,
the story is that this video was used to
be shown to middleschoolers back in the
90s to help inform them about,
I guess this is one like the pedophile
scare started when every random mail,
specifically males was looking to abduct
you.
So this,
this little short here was meant to
educate the fine innocent young children
of America.
And to avoiding being taken.
So here I give you the pedo hunting
dinosaur.
Yeah.
Hi Yellow Dano here,
Bro.
I'm going to tell you straight up if
there's any pedophile,
it's in that fucking suit.
Listen to that voice,
man.
I don't tell you what else.
There's enough space in that suit for a
man and a child like he could.
He could be like clemen my suit.
Young one.
Hi there.
Whoa.
Damn.
You're about to see a show for parents
and children about tricking people.
Now if you're wondering who tricky
people
people,
that's a nice way to say child rapist.
Ah,
well just put it bluntly.
They're people who want to harm
children.
Drink it,
drink it,
drink it.
People everywhere you look it could,
well you're trying to fuck.
And also what's wrong with you?
Like why?
Like this dinosaur character is just so
strange.
He's like,
I look in everywhere.
If there's rapists everywhere,
it's like at a certain point,
if you see them that frequently,
you're looking too hard.
Maybe you're looking,
you need to look inward like this.
Dinosaurs,
there's a real true pat o'hare.
I mean really,
and it kind of,
my name is reginald charming.
I put the show on here today.
Cool.
Did I just miss your mom
by the way?
This is like the main villain was this
name Reginald charming.
Yeah,
his last name charming.
It's like these guys are fucking the
guys who made this our,
I swear to God,
you'll have to touch kids to dream the
shit up.
Like you have to have at least have a
couple of children and your slavery
dungeon.
The dream of this yellow jazz talking
Dinosaur Anti Child Rape Superhero and
the name of villain.
Mr Charming.
I'm mister charming.
Okay,
so you use it on the little kids today.
Something subtle like asking them,
oh no,
no,
no.
Wait,
I've got some bumpy.
Why the fuck did they sound like Chris
Rock?
Oh No,
not the old puppies in the car.
He's fucking regional though to,
he's like citizen justice.
I don't know what they're advocating,
but this guy hasn't raped any kids and
you're loving you're,
you're strong.
Arming him against a wall man.
Also,
it's like such a Chris rock
impersonation.
It's tripping me out as a great shit.
Imagine being in middle school and
trying to extrapolate meaning from this.
This is just so insane.
Is he explicitly a dinosaur?
I don't know what else he could be.
Yeah,
it's fucking weird.
Maybe he's you.
Did you see sin city where they chop off
the pedals balls and he turns yellow?
Maybe that's what this is.
Oh Shit.
This is like the devolution and he's a
yellow man.
Yeah,
he's a castrated pedophile.
Oh,
I'm an upstanding citizen
dude.
This shit so fucked up.
He tricks all these little girls and
into doing a photo shoot for him and
he's in there taking photos and look at
it as creepy.
A little friend like cheering them on
and then at the end,
which I'll show you the dinosaur breaks
into his office to get the photos.
It's amazing.
It was all a sting operation and the
rest of the dinosaur you'll see there.
There's a twist in between the lines,
which I'd like you guys to watch your
budget.
There's a lot to unpack here and I'm
really not sure.
What's the meaning?
I think the meaning is the lizards,
the Pedo,
every once the pedo trust.
Nobody at all.
Wow.
This whole pedo hysteria.
It's so strange.
Like I don't know that there was this
crazy pedo hysteria when I was this age.
But these days it's like,
don't,
uh,
don't play outside by yourself or
there's a hundred percent chance that
someone's going to rape you immediately.
It's like how many immediately you're
innovating a rapist pedals are out there
lurking.
I don't know.
It's never got show one of these when
you were growing up though.
No,
cause I,
not this one,
but I explicitly remember the pedo video
when I was like in elementary school,
by the way.
We have the Dan Cam up.
We do.
Oh Great.
How's it look?
Well,
I'm not on it right now.
Oh,
have you guys seen the Dan camp?
We haven't used it yet.
It's hit the Dan Cam.
You're talking,
it's,
it's hard to explain,
but if I'm just sitting here like an
idiot like this and you're talking hit
the damn camp,
but then nobody's in the Dan Kim right
now.
Oh,
you're not going to Dan Cam.
Yeah,
we've got Ian screening calls.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
I know.
All right,
let me just play it.
I'm going to cut to Dan Cameron.
It's just an empty room.
Alright.
Um,
I never,
I was never shown any that's on the Dan
Cameron.
All right.
Dan Camp.
I was never shown any anything like
this.
You know,
all you get is like a don't get in a car
with strangers.
I mean,
what more do you need to know?
Don't take,
if some can't guys offering you candy,
you know,
don't let them put a finger in your ass
unless it's like a full tootsie roll.
Definitely not for like a little to
zero.
That's not worth the finger in the ass.
No bite size bullshit.
Full on like king size to cheer all you
could basically put fit four fingers up
my ass even today,
frankly speaking.
Good to know.
It was a great,
all right,
well you got a tootsie roll.
Okay,
I will later tonight you have a dinosaur
costume.
You want to role play?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Your hands off her.
Oh by the way,
his voice changes from,
he goes from,
okay,
it goes from,
uh,
what's his name?
Chris.
Chris Rock.
And he goes from Chris Rock that Bruce
Willis.
Real quick,
man,
get your hands off.
Washes.
Take Lyrica is really,
how did he change your race?
His voice changed race.
I thought that was why
I didn't do anything good out of my
office.
I want Carmen's pictures.
That's Ed.
Looks like a nipple on my right.
Fucking got him that record on the wall.
So fucking nipple got them.
What are you talking about?
Pictures.
Oh my God.
I don't know what Carmen told you,
but there are no pictures.
Give me the combination.
Charming.
Figure it out.
You big stupid lizard.
You think you're so smart?
Well,
you can't watch them all the time.
Nobody can.
Cool.
Goodness takes off with the scare me.
You're just jealous because of the kids
liked me better than,
than like you.
Right?
Maybe there's something to that.
You hear me right?
So the question is
target
the photos,
those that is not,
that is not admissible evidence.
So the question I have is where's he
going with those photos?
You know what I'm saying?
You can't use those in court.
You just barged in and stolen out of his
safe.
So what exactly is he doing with those
photos?
Yeah.
I mean he didn't show up at the cops.
He's just kind of this vigilante.
You kicked in the doors,
stole the child porn and he's going
home.
He's going straight home with that.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Just like Yo,
share the fucking wealth man.
I loved how dramatic that got that.
Like Take Kiki and get outta here.
Like looking over your shoulder.
Yeah,
man,
he's going to go beat off to those
photos.
I've never been sure of anything more in
my life.
So that's a weird one that,
that really,
I don't know.
That threw me for a loop.
That video.
That was wild dude.
They used to put kids in a,
you know,
auditorium,
the whole class 500 people or whatever.
I don't,
yeah,
and watch this.
I mean,
what I wish I had been shown that one,
the one I was shown was super awkward
and just serious.
You know what I mean?
Right.
I did not have probably a better
approach because I'm not sure I could
extrapolate any means.
Avoid yellow dinosaurs.
Anyway,
that's the goof of the day.
I hope you guys had fun with that.
Give it up.
Wasn't that a good time everybody?
Well we are.
We have,
we have fun out here.
They should.
Guest experience.
Don't wait.
We have a lot of fun here.
Um,
let's get onto the main stories.
Logan.
Paul.
Wow.
Who's ever talked about him.
Am I right?
Is that while there was this one tweet,
I honestly couldn't let it go.
I had to show it to you guys because it
really was so insane.
Um,
that
even,
even now I read it and I was just like,
whoa.
Right.
He erased it after shortly after
tweeting it because everyone was just
like,
wow,
this is insane.
So this is only from a couple of days
ago.
He says,
and I quote board the plane,
flight attendant gives me the old
eyeball,
up and down high socks,
short shorts,
saggy blonde hair.
She shaggy,
saggy tits picture.
Perfect.
Fuck boy.
Give him my ticket first class stunned.
He goes,
oh wow.
And points me to my seat.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
Wow.
God,
what a hero.
There's,
there's a lot to actually unpack here.
I feel like,
well,
first of all,
this never happened.
Let's just establish this right off the
bat.
Bullshit.
The only thing it's missing is everybody
in the airplane standing up and
applauding.
Big applause.
Yeah.
Albert Einstein gave him that and the
only thing that's missing is that flight
attendant,
Albert Einstein.
This never fucking happened,
dude.
At this point,
you're like 24 there's no excuse for
running this shit.
This is like what a 12 year old
fantasizes about.
Then second of all,
he acknowledges that he dresses like a
fucking clown.
High socks,
shorts,
shaggy,
blonde hair picture.
Perfect fuckboy picture.
If you're a fuck,
if you're going to sit there and
acknowledge that you look like an idiot
and that you're a fuckboy,
let's just change your outfit.
He's basically,
you know what he's saying is I'm wearing
all maverick shit to sell it to these
kids,
but I would never want to wear this
because I look like a fuck boy.
But I do like there's something in
there,
you know there's a weird motor come have
a self awareness buried in there for
sure.
Like who is this flight attendant?
This never seen a rich person who's
apparently works first class,
their flight attendant.
Oh Wow.
Oh my God,
you're first class.
Just imagine this person.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my God.
Oh Wow.
I am so sorry I judged you.
Okay.
And then of course the subtle bragging
about being rich and flying first class.
But what exactly are you asking?
Not to judge.
There's no nothing about your character.
He's saying don't,
don't make a judgment if someone's a
rich or poor.
Okay.
Be careful who you're rude too because
they might be rich.
The fuck.
What's the moral of the story,
Logan?
He's trying to bring awareness to the
rampant persecution of fuck boys in this
country that honestly is probably the
biggest social issue that we have to
deal with it.
And not denying that he's a fuck boy.
He's like,
I'm a rich fuckboy and therefore you
judged a book by its cover.
It's like,
dude,
basically he's saying because he's
wealthy,
he's superior.
I mean,
that's really what's sewn in here.
Okay.
And to that I say,
and you are fucking,
uh,
really,
this is really one of the worst tweets
I've ever read.
And he always says,
I'm a kid and he always has a 30 year
old man and all that shit.
He would call me at 33 year old man.
You're,
that excuse is not,
I mean,
this is really probably the dumbest
thing I've ever read by a public
personality.
How long did he keep this up before he
was 30,000
likes?
So I mean,
probably half a day or more.
Was he getting a bunch of shit for it?
Like what?
Yeah,
I'm sure.
How did he become self aware suddenly
that that is fucking awful.
Yeah.
He was probably getting shit for it and
he was,
he's probably trying to play it like
close to the hip these days,
you know?
Um,
he's like,
Ooh,
I guess he's like,
I don't understand why people don't like
this,
but I'm going to remove it because
trying to keep it,
you know,
coach.
But I have to say I,
when I read this,
I said stunned.
I said,
oh wow.
And then you stood up and started
applauding.
Right.
And then I did judge this book by its
cover.
I was like,
well no,
they were right about you,
dude.
They weren't talking about the price.
The fact that you are first class,
they were talking about that you're such
a douchebag.
They saw this,
they saw him,
they knew it was Logan Paul.
And they're like,
Oh wow,
this guy's a fucking idiot.
And then Logan's like,
excuse me,
I'm first class.
And they're like,
yeah,
you're still,
you're,
that's exactly what I expected.
You're a fucking idiot.
This is a Marv.
I must want to frame this.
You know what I mean?
We should wait.
What is a picture?
Perfect fuck boy.
By the way.
Oh,
when you,
when you had done that self image.
We don't make someone aware,
but it's only got a negative
connotation.
You don't know what a picture.
Perfect.
Fuck boys.
It's high socks,
shorts,
shaggy blonde hair.
Right,
right.
Basically describing and laying it out.
Right.
He's a pimp or picture.
Perfect.
Fuck.
But I love it.
I want to frame,
this is the dumbest thing I've ever
read.
I mean,
genuinely,
I've always,
I've reserved judgment for him and I'm
like,
he's smart.
Like he's old.
He's young,
he's reckless,
he's crazy.
But he's,
he's smart.
No,
no.
The verdict's out.
This book has been read.
The covers flipped this books read.
We're not judging it by the cover.
Logan.
We've read the fucking book.
It's a bad book.
It's a shitty buck dead.
It's,
it's frankly this book and I think
you'll agree it's in the bargain bin.
You can buy this book for like $2 on
sale right now.
Kmart.
Yeah.
It couldn't even get it into a walmart.
It's just kmart.
This is in the bar.
This,
this book is frankly on sale at a
salvation army right now for 50 cents.
Yeah.
We've read the book.
Well,
anyway,
I want to talk about the press
conference he had with Ksi.
And again,
I don't want to talk about everything
pillow and Paul does,
but this stuff is so good and I got to
say,
well,
let's take a break.
We'll talk about it when we get back.
We've got the press conference to talk
about.
We've got BBC had an interview scheduled
for him today to promote his fight with
KSI that they canceled.
They said it wasn't a good interview.
That canceled.
I love that,
that and so,
so,
so much more.
And of course know your meme.
Don't go anywhere guys.
We will be right back.
Thank you to ring for sponsoring this
episode of the podcast.
Let me tell you about ring this product.
It's one of these genius products that
is so perfect time and place.
It changed my life.
Let me show you this.
It's this little doorbell that goes over
your existing doorbell or if you don't
even have a doorbell,
you can put it and it's got a battery
that lasts a long time.
It's got a microphone so you can talk to
WHO's out there.
It's got a camera with a motion
detector.
So if someone's creeping in front of
your door or it's just the mailman or
pizzas here,
they ring,
they walk,
it opens a feed on your phone.
You can also check it any time,
regardless of motion and talk to them.
Leave the package,
knock on the door,
whatever.
This thing is changing the fricking game
here you see in the bottom right.
That's what it looks like.
You can talk,
you can see them.
It's so fricking powerful and amazing.
You know these guys were on shark tank
and you know what?
Mark Cuban and everybody there said to
him for those reasons amount.
You know what?
I'm out shark tank because ring went on.
I think it's the most successful company
that they all passed on their,
it's like $1 billion company now and you
know what?
And I say to them,
no,
maybe I'm relying on the switchboard a
little too much,
but I'll tell you what,
I am relying on ring.
Okay?
They're making neighborhoods safer.
They are helping connect your home
anywhere in the world.
If you're on vacation,
you still see what's going on at your
front door.
You get the motion,
you get it all because it's on the
Internet telling you this thing's
incredible.
It's got hd video and two way audio
features changing the game.
I got to tell you,
I have creepy people that should come to
our house.
That happens.
I can and it saves it to the cloud.
So if some cribs coming to my front door
that I don't want there,
it saves to the cloud.
I got you sucker.
I know if I want to talk to her that
it's my mom.
I'm not.
No,
I'm kidding.
But you could use it that way.
Was that through rude?
As a listener,
you have a special offer on a ring
starter kit available right now with a
video doorbell and motion activated
floodlight camp.
The starter kit has everything you need
to start building a ring of security
around your home.
Go to ring.com/h
three that's a ring.com/age
three
whoa.
Oh,
Didn't see you there.
I was just changing my life with this
quip electric toothbrush.
You hear that?
That's the pulsating and vibrating
goodness that is smack dab a loaded
inside this incredible toothbrush that
Oprah has.
Literally put a hunter Oh list.
Let me tell you about this thing.
If you're listening to the show and you
have not yet got a quip,
then I'm not telling you enough.
It's the,
I'm obsessed with oral hygiene.
Okay?
Giant bulky electric toothbrushes are
out of the question.
Those things cost $20 and it's about the
size of a car battery not bringing that
thing with me anywhere.
This gives you the same pulsing action
and this little vibrating too.
On top of that,
it tells you when to switch sides
because let's be honest,
you're not brushing enough.
We all know we're a bunch of sloppy,
nasty mouth Fox that don't brush our
teeth and,
and that's why your breath stinks and
nobody wants to fucking kiss you or be
within a foot of you.
This is going to change everything for
you,
tells you when to switch sides.
It tells you when you're done brushing,
I think it's like three minutes and you
know you're getting a perfect brush
every fricking time.
With quip.
It's
affordable
to
starts@twentyfivedollarsifyougottogetquip.com
slash h three right now,
you'll get your first refill pack for
free with the quip electric toothbrush.
My friends,
that's your first refill.
Pack free.
We're talking about the head here
because this battery,
this little tube lasts a long time.
This head,
you flip it out every three months and
you are good to go.
So you get your first refill pack free
at [inaudible] dot com slash hd that's
ge Ti Qui p.com/h
three my friends,
it's dentist recommended oprah loves it.
What more do you need to know other than
that,
and let me tell you,
I frickin love this toothbrush.
Try it right flipping.
Now
you've all heard me talking about me on
these and if you haven't made them move
to get these RMDS,
you're slacking underwear.
More like funder where and yes,
you can quote me on that.
Me undies Sushi.
Oh,
cereal and milk.
Forget about it.
All right,
but the look is kind of the least of it.
It's about the comfort.
It's about material that is softer than
cotton,
more breathable,
and can cradle your junk like nothing on
the market.
Now you guys have seen me,
dude,
the atomic wedgie test.
Okay?
Now I defy you to find any other brand
that you can comfortably pull above your
tits.
That's the me undies guarantee or your
money back.
No,
that's my guarantee.
Listen,
it's so soft.
It's so breathable.
Extreme my mouth from my balls.
It's insane.
Okay.
It sustainably sourced.
It's made from beechwood.
Do the math on that.
I don't know how it's possible to turn a
tree and to this,
but they're got scientists on the job
right now.
Trust me.
When you put on a pair,
you're going to get it all right.
Now they've got,
uh,
another thing.
Check this out.
I'm just fully nude at this point.
If you like.
How may undies fields on your just
underwear.
Imagine how it feels your whole body.
You could see my junk.
It's like a full on zoom on my junk.
It feels great.
That's the me undies pledge.
Okay.
Forget about it.
Here's the best part about Mandy's.
It's risk free.
You're like,
oh,
it's just underwear.
Try it out.
And if you don't,
absolutely love it,
no questions asked to going to give you
a refund.
It's risk-free best underwear ever.
So if you're already part of the Mandy's
fam,
tell your friends about it through the
referral program and you'll get a
discount and store credit when,
when?
Still not sure.
Well,
Mandy's has a deal for my listeners.
First Time purchasers will get 15% off
their first pair of me,
Andy's and free shipping.
That's 15% off plus free shipping and a
guarantee that you and your Mandy's will
be very,
very happy together.
So get your butt on over to Mandy's end.
Treat yourself to get 50% off your first
pair,
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed.
Go to Mandy's dotcom slash.
H sorry,
that's me,
Andy's dot com slash h three and give
yourself an atomic wedgie well below
above your tits and I nsf is going to
feel good.
Frankly.
You're going to want to walk around like
that.
That's Mandy's personal guarantee to
you.
Alrighty,
we are back.
Thanks for sticking around.
So he's on firstclass.
He's going somewhere clearly.
Where's he going?
I think I know where he's going.
Follow the lead.
I've got it all tracked out.
The press conference with CSI,
CSI.
Jesus.
Ksi sound like an old man.
Um,
who's this CSI guy?
Yeah,
exactly.
So Ksi Logan.
Paul,
you guys all know about this boxing
match.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm going to watch the highlights.
I'm not going to sit here in front.
Like what?
Like I'm not even interested on aunt.
I'm going to watch the highlights.
I'm watching it.
I actually,
I think this side is going to,
I think Ksi will win,
but I am standing by that I think is
going to be a shitty,
boring match ever since I heard.
So they're doing two,
one in the UK and one back here in La
and they always arrange for it to do
too.
I feel like it's,
it's all bogus.
Like one is going to win one and the
other is going to win the other.
Ah,
I don't think,
I don't what you're,
you're saying that someone's going to
throw it?
Yeah,
I'm not going full conspiracy,
man.
I don't think it's legit.
I don't think either of them have
neither have,
they both have such huge egos.
I don't think either of them have it and
them to get their ass beat and throw.
I don't see it.
Hmm.
But if there's like a slaughter and the
first one,
I mean,
I have no reason to believe it's weird
to have.
Well anyway,
whatever.
Let's watch his fucking video could sit
here and analyze this all.
It's just a bunch of fucking youtube or
xbox it like,
it's retard.
Like the concept is just so stupid.
They're gonna make so much money.
Dude,
hold onto the stage.
Anyway,
watching this video,
I actually start to feel bad for Logan
Paul in a way.
He's just,
he gets,
he's the heel.
He just can't go wrestling hill.
So embarrassing.
Like he just gets creamed by case.
I then Logan's Logan's dad of all people
come out and try to defend him.
It's like,
Dude,
his dad is crunchy as fuck and it's just
like a shit show.
It's just so embarrassing.
You know what Logan's thinking?
He's like,
dude,
this is my,
this may well be my last chance to make
money.
Okay,
so I'm going to ignore this.
I wonder how much they both making from
this.
I want to crunch some numbers right now.
Let's crunch numbers.
I think there's 20,000
seats.
I don't think they're going to sell it.
I think maybe they'll sell.
Let's be generous and say they sell
10,000
seats.
Okay.
10,000.
Let's say it's 100 on average per
ticket.
And they get let's,
let's just do revenue right now.
Okay.
There wasn't charging a hundred fucking
dollars.
I can do this thing.
Yeah,
she's,
so that's a million.
But then they're doing paper view and
all this bullshit.
They'll have a lot of live streamers.
I know.
How many,
how many paper view tickets can they
sell this?
I don't know.
Not that much.
10,000.
I mean,
I don't know.
Right
for the online,
isn't it online thing?
Yeah,
it's a online page charging for that
too.
Wow.
Um,
they'll still more than 10,000,
let's say it's 25 for the stream.
So what do you think they sell?
I mean,
I,
okay,
let's say 50 that seems generous,
but maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe it's a hundred I don't know.
50,000
that's another,
I mean,
you're looking at 2 million.
Not Bad for the venue gets half.
You're down to a million split between
the two of them.
I feel like this calculation can't be
right.
I feel like they got to be making more
money from this.
You know,
it's $14 for an online ticket.
It looks like dude,
they're fucking not making that much
money from this.
He's humiliating himself for like a
hundred I mean,
maybe I'm out of touch a little bit.
Most people are like,
dude,
I would eat my own shit for $100,000
and you're right.
But like Mcgregor,
like mayweather got paid 300 million
fucking dollars or something.
How much should he get for that fight?
I don't know.
Look it up.
I'm sure it's somewhere around there.
Like so you know,
in comparison,
which is what they're trying to do
regardless is washes.
I am very curious how much money
they're,
you know,
about to make from it.
If you can look that up,
let me know,
Dan.
Yeah,
I just pulled it up.
300 million for mayweather and conor
Mcgregor.
Hundred around a hundred million.
I don't know.
Fuck.
Is there that much money in a single
fight?
The fighters alone got $400 million.
What am I missing?
Well,
okay,
well what I'm missing is that that was
like the fight of the century and
probably like a million plus people
bought the paper view,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it's two legends,
you know?
Uh,
KSI and Logan Paul.
I mean they're legends.
Bit of a,
of a different,
gosh,
I'm really care.
I don't see that many people buying the
paper view because everyone is just
going to want to watch the highlights.
Just don't.
H three h three a live reaction stream
built leg there.
Bootleg tape review.
That might be illegal.
Come at me fuckers.
No,
I'm not
right
this dick again.
Yeah.
You already did this dad.
Dude,
come on the fuck off.
Oh,
you know what?
Let me just skip to the good parts,
which is basically he shits on him.
He shits on em.
Let's go.
Let's all doors.
Fuck.
I really liked when his dad gets
involved.
You see everyone has,
everyone has my back.
Yeah,
you're an old man.
Okay.
Here's when the dad gets him in this.
This is disgusting.
Delusional Times.
He's not wrong.
You're disgusting man.
His Dad is there on stage.
Why is your dad there?
Doug?
You're trying to look bad ass.
Don't bring your fucking dad.
Who makes out with little girls?
Yeah,
I was about to say this is the same dad
that they got the keys.
He's like,
you know what?
It'd be bad ass at this press
conference.
My Dad don't judge a book by its cover.
You fucking peasant ass.
Stewardist you know what's funny about
Logan Paul?
He probably buys his data coach ticket
cause they come here as like an
entourage.
You know Logan Paul is the kind of dude
who would buy himself a first class
ticket in his dad's and coach.
Listen Dad,
you're not,
you're not a firstclass fuck boy like
me.
All right,
you got to run this and dad,
the entourage is pretty big.
I'm going to have to stick you in coach.
All the way back next to the bathroom.
Don't judge a book by its cover,
Dude.
Don't you have a job?
How was this his,
how was his dad turned into his hype?
Man,
don't you have a job?
Okay.
He's like,
my son is really famous.
I'm going to ride his coattails and kiss
as many little 16 year olds as possible.
His Dad is like all in like he's Logan
Paul's dad now.
Like he walks around and people are
like,
Oh,
you're that guy that makes up a little
girls and Jake Paul's channel.
Yeah.
Anyway,
do premium premium.
The fuck you want to do?
Shit,
you're an old man.
I mean,
that's just factual.
He's like,
you're an old man.
It's not really even how to install it.
Just like we're not an equal fighting
match.
You're an old man,
so yeah,
that is true.
I'm so,
I'm so you wouldn't mind lots of one on
the phone.
A little.
She like kissing so good.
He's fucking dad is getting roasted
team.
Paul,
look,
he wants to get in there.
You sit dead bald headed prick.
I like this guy is I,
to be honest.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
by the way,
look at Jake Paul on the top left
looking like Elton John.
Bro.
What the fuck?
The eighties called?
You see him?
No,
you see him right here.
Look at this.
The,
he looks like he looks like night at the
Roxbury.
His ass looking fuck.
Hold on.
Let's take it full screen.
Do you not see this?
My crazy?
No,
you're not crazy,
jake.
Paul's looking like he's out for the
night of the Roxbury's.
Dude,
that's the one that's minimized as it is
it viewable on the stream though?
We can't see it.
It's like cut off for don't fucks it up.
Hold on.
No,
this is important,
but there is,
you can't see full screen.
Where you mean it was just crop.
It just the very,
cause he's right on the edge.
It was just cut off ever so slightly.
We see it now.
Okay.
Why does it look like Jake?
Paul is about to drop the corneas 80
single right now.
[inaudible] damn.
The whole team is just,
that's a whole bunch of winners,
right?
Jake Paul,
dude,
I can't get over this luck.
He's not even there.
He's like out in outer space.
He's like,
zone the fuck out.
He's like watching cartoons in his head
right now.
Blue tinted glasses night at the Roxbury
ass looking fuck.
Okay.
I think maybe he's just like reflecting
on how embarrassed he is of his dad.
Do you have that kind of know his dad's,
his role model.
Tim Paul,
Tom as children.
Here we go.
You want to ask you about ask your mom.
Got Him
fucking God.
Get Him Dad.
My Dad got you.
Good.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
My Dad just burned you.
Okay.
Hey Dad,
you want to take care of the Hey dad,
you want to get the mic can take care of
this.
Hey Dad,
this Guy Ksi.
He's Talkin Shit.
You want to get take care of this.
What does he do?
What does his dad do?
I wonder like what's his job now?
Probably nothing right now,
but he's clearly,
he's clearly,
I wonder what's his job within the
organization?
You know what I mean?
Got Jake.
Paul is such a phony.
He looks like someone who's trying to be
someone else.
I don't know,
whatever.
He's a commercial roofer and licensed
realtor.
You're ready.
Oh,
he is.
All right.
It just looked it up according to
priceless.
He is.
He is a realtor.
They honestly,
frankly,
all these Polish should be realtors.
Like I was talking last episode about
like why Youtube makes people famous.
You have no right to be these Paul
brothers have a law.
They have a legacy and being realtors,
they should have a realtor family
business or are they all just selling
houses in Ohio?
Should be on a bus stops.
I can see Logan Paul with a receding
hairline.
He's at a house,
you know,
a couple hours for the client shows up.
He's cleaning,
making sure it's nice.
Yeah.
There's all three of their faces on a
bus stop and a little murky.
Yeah.
The question I said,
let's do some questions.
Don't throw anything.
Calm down.
All right.
I know.
Hey,
I'm gonna be honest.
Fuck you.
He looks like he's heartbroken right
now.
Fuck you.
Loca he looks like a broken man.
Did how you feel about,
is that lip?
How's that lit?
Hey,
I was here and answer your questions.
All right.
I feel like Ksi address everything.
I'm out August 25th Oh,
you just Mike Bale's.
Yeah,
exactly.
Case I've lived in.
Fuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
It was butter I think.
I think,
dude,
he's not in a good place.
Logan.
I think he's,
yeah.
Anyway,
we talking about it.
He's,
he's gotta be so happy.
No,
but his dad's got his fucking back.
Yeah.
His Dad's got his back through thick and
thin for sure.
And then on top of it,
BBC was at an interview with Logan to
promote the fight and they tweeted this
out today.
We were going to hear from Logan,
Paul and Ksi on their boxing match
tonight after listening back to the
interview.
And we don't feel it's right.
We understand some of your strong views
on Logan,
but ultimately we don't,
if we don't think the interview is good
enough,
we don't air it.
They thought the interview,
they're like,
it's not about that.
You guys don't like Logan.
It's about that the interview sucked
that this guy at nothing interesting to
say.
And so we didn't air it like this is the
best burn ever.
That like we acknowledge that we all
hate him and that's not why we aired it.
We aired it because it sucked.
Dick,
it's pretty brutal man.
He would be a killer realtor though.
He could probably,
yeah,
he would be killed realtor.
I buy the trailer parks from him.
All right,
well,
um,
guys,
it's about that time for an episode of I
to sneeze.
Oh God.
[inaudible]
all right.
An episode,
an episode of know your meme.
That's right.
Everybody.
Welcome to another episode of know your
meme.
Today's episode is about your favorite
virgin,
the,
the virgin.
We've got callers lined up to play.
So with that being said,
let's take a call from our very first
player.
We have got a,
which was the one you liked.
Uh,
and it was,
I don't see her anymore.
It was a Rachel did Rachel Bounce Rachel
Dam and helped me quick.
All right,
I'm just going to take one.
We've got,
he's got,
he said he put it in priority order.
Okay,
let's do this.
Uh,
nick,
you are on the air.
Are you ready to play?
Know your meme.
Alright,
I dropped that.
That was not a good quality call and
frankly this is no time for playing
around.
Okay,
I'm booing that.
Next up we've got Sarah.
Sarah,
it's a tough crowd
on the air.
Are you ready to play?
No.
Your ma'am.
I am most ready.
Oh,
most ready?
Okay.
I liked the sound of that.
Sarah,
how are you?
I am very good.
You're very calm.
I liked that about you.
You've got your shit together.
You got your game face on.
Where are you from?
Okay.
I am from Wisconsin.
Oh,
cheese,
right.
That's the whole thing.
Do you like cheese?
I love cheese.
I excellent,
very good.
Very good.
Round of applause.
Do you like to Sarah loves cheese.
Okay,
great.
I feel like I know you already.
So are you playing the answers cause I
don't have them on my computer.
I have the answers or cued up.
Ready to go.
Okay.
First question.
Who is skippy's celebrity crush?
Is it a Emma Watson?
Be Oprah Winfrey or c going old school?
Gwenyth paltrow a or c maybe.
Seems like a classy man.
Yeah,
that's a good guess.
She's a business lady.
She's industrious.
She's got a lot going on.
Dan,
is it c?
My celebrity crash as the number one?
Uh,
I think that Oprah is one of the most
amazing people on the planet or any
celebrity.
It would be oprah.
I want to be around Oprah.
Wow.
He wants to be around Oprah.
I have to say that one was a little
unexpected.
Skippy wants to Bang Oprah.
That surprises me.
Franklin.
Would it be my first choice?
Either,
but I'm very good guess,
but don't worry you a former questions.
There's still time.
Let's move it on to question two.
How are you feeling?
Are you ready?
Are you prepared?
I,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm pretty prepared.
I think your weight,
you're almost too calm,
but that's okay.
Okay.
How many girls has skippy kissed?
Zero.
A.
Okay.
B Nine or c?
49.
I'm going to go with B.
Wow.
No hesitation.
What?
What,
what?
What makes you think that?
It's 49.
I know he's gotten to a second and a
half base.
Really?
A couple of times.
Okay.
She eats cheese and she watches skippy.
I love it.
Fuck yeah.
Okay guys,
that's the life.
Dan,
you ready?
Go ahead.
How many girls have eyecare?
Plenty.
That's a really easy thing for me to
remember.
It's 49.
It's warm.
Yeah.
Excellent.
I got to say that shocked me when I
heard he had kissed 49 cuties.
I was like,
damn,
skippy is fucking like crazy.
Like if he wasn't a mormon,
he would be like probably have stds
still mag.
Would you get skippy?
Okay.
Uh,
I would give that a soft.
Maybe
you give him a peck.
Hmm.
Yeah.
You give them a soft,
what does that mean?
Like a soft kiss?
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
it would be like a,
I feel sorry for you a little bit.
We can't make it to the next stage.
Not the type.
Who's your consolation prize?
Do you,
are you attracted to men who picked
belly button lint out of their stomach
and keep it in a jar by their bed?
No,
I would have to say probably not.
Well,
I find that a little bit judgmental,
Sarah,
but,
but you are your own person and I don't
judge you.
You've got one point on the board.
Hey,
so excellent.
Here we go.
Question number three,
what's the furthest Bay skippy has
gotten too?
Hey,
second and a half.
In other words,
he's,
he's fingered girls and he's got his
dick touched as well.
Oh,
third base
oral or first base,
which is,
you know,
just a peck.
He seem to know a lot about.
Yeah.
Okay.
I hear you describing the basis,
the basis.
Um,
I think it's a,
you sound confident.
No hesitation.
Nope.
Zero hesitation.
Knocking around the skippy knowledge.
Wow.
You're good.
Well,
I like to,
I liked when the music gets tense.
I feel like you're not giving me a
chance.
Like,
you know,
you got to let the tension build.
You're too confident.
You're too quiet.
Oh my bad.
Okay.
I'll wait for the next one.
Nobody.
You could be yourself but also don't be
yourself to make the show better,
Dan.
The answer is
done.
Well,
let's just put it there.
Okay.
I was going between second and third,
but I ended up getting tagged out by the
sheriff.
Stopped.
I'd been touched in the side
but haven't quite gotten the fat where
mountains on body parts had gotten her.
I get it.
I guess I have
the say your knowledge of skippy.
You got your all,
you've got two points on the board.
I may give it up,
man.
It's the second he must say that because
you haven't mentioned this,
that yeah,
you knew right away.
Uh,
I may or may not have brushed up on my
skippy knowledge.
Oh,
you're an advanced player.
I,
I definitely tip my beanie to you now.
He said he's gotten that second and a
half base.
If you had to imagine,
what do you think that would necessarily
mean?
Uh,
like his dick out a little bit wet,
but not crazy way.
Little like a little kiss,
like a little kid.
Interesting.
A little bit kiss here.
Can I do a,
uh,
can I do,
there's gotta be a sound effect for
that.
Yeah,
I imagine you're right.
Probably got a little bit wet and to
that I said once again,
skip that you really surprising me.
If it wasn't for this a little warming
thing,
he would just be fucking like crazy.
He's crushing it honestly.
I know.
I love the image of him being stopped
between bases.
Like he got,
he got tagged out.
He was in,
he's having a pickle and probably came
downstairs.
Yeah,
that might be actually accurate.
What happened?
Your left.
All right.
Just once for all the tamales.
Oh Man.
What's the most trouble skips trouble
skippy has ever gotten with his bishop?
We've taught,
heard him talk about his bishop.
This is the man at his church who passes
judgment on him.
He's basically the gatekeeper to the
afterlife.
Right,
right.
So a,
um,
he got in trouble for all the handies
he's been getting
no,
as we,
as we've called it,
rounding the third base,
but being struck out for masturbating
too much or see getting drunk,
which is strictly against the Mormon
faith.
Sarah,
what is your oh boy.
I think deeply and the mind of the
Mormon enter the mind of the virgin.
I would say it's probably masturbating,
masturbating too much.
Very nice and very,
very good gas.
I would guess that he masturbates at
least seven times a day at least.
Dan,
is it masturbating too much,
John
to second base with multiple girls?
I got if we're using the baseball
analogy,
I uh,
got sidelined by my bishop and was told
not to take the communion for awhile.
So in the Mormon church they call it
being disfellowshipped.
This fella
shipped.
It is sadly,
he had a great,
great guess.
You had a great guess.
He probably does masturbate a lot to
that.
I would give you all the credit,
but it was actually from all the handies
he was getting and he got
disfellowshipped,
which is a word that makes me giggle.
Um,
I love it.
But this is okay.
This last question.
Everything rides on this question.
It's two to two.
This is,
we are on the board to,
to,
to the tents.
Music is on now.
Sarah,
what kind of phone are you using
currently?
I am using a Google Pixel that has a
very craft screen.
Oh,
so this is,
this has been,
because this is big.
Let me tell you what's on the line here.
Okay.
This is a brand new s nine plus.
This is the best phone on the market.
There's no question about it.
And let me tell you what else.
What else do you think it has my dna on
it.
Ooh,
don't clone you.
Terrific.
Okay,
I won't.
Sorry.
35 okay,
here we go.
The question to decide at all
what?
Ooh,
what kind of collection did skippy give
us?
The auction for charity.
Was it a toe nail clippings be eyelashes
or see belly button.
It was definitely fee and smelled like
your grandmother's closet here and one
of the cooler things I get that I did.
I was,
I was drawing it out.
I didn't say go.
I played it early.
Dan,
you heard the drama.
You play it.
The symbol.
Do you,
when you hear this my entire life,
don't you play when you did the symbol?
I'm not.
I'm describing.
I did.
Don't get technical.
You know what I mean?
That doesn't mean play.
I'm just telling you when I hit that.
All right.
Yeah.
What is the answer?
One of the cooler
planes that ever happened in my entire
life was when my belly button link
collection of almost 20 years was given
to h three h three
what's the greatest,
greatest fall on the market?
How are you feeling right now?
I am so excited.
Oh,
I'm happy to hear that.
Do you have anyone that you want to
think?
Uh,
I'd like to think it's my baby girl for
sleeping during this entire process.
God bless her.
What a sweet Angela.
Oh,
Dan told him to kill the music.
I guess that was not really that great.
It's just a little louder.
Um,
Sarah,
you're the greatest.
You don't want a new phone.
Stay on the line.
We're going to hook you up.
Thank you for calling in and God will
look good.
Yep.
Thank you.
Appreciate Ya.
All right,
Papa.
Bless Papa.
Bless.
Do I need to mute her?
Something down?
Yeah,
just put her,
uh,
don't,
don't take this personally,
Sarah,
but I get it.
You're muted.
Shut up Dan.
You got it.
I'm doing,
I'm doing drum out here.
I know I milk.
I'm doing drama.
You can't just be,
you can't willy nilly just play sound
whenever you want.
Oh,
unbelievable.
You hear this?
That's drama.
I didn't hit the center of the civil.
Where'd the money went for hurricane
relief?
I hear the symbol,
right.
Play.
Not Kidding,
dude.
Anyway.
That was fun.
That was a good time.
Sarah was a great color.
There was a great guy.
I love this.
I love this segment.
It's so much fun that my dna on it send
any into uh,
get her info.
I was great.
And that was so much fun.
Who should we do next?
I wonder.
So we actually,
this show is,
uh,
let's just do the Roseanne.
I mean I've got a lot of great stuff
here,
but I kind of want to go over it with,
with Ila.
Um,
one thing in particular I really want to
talk about is that we talked previously
that mean either trying to have kids.
So I want to do a semen analysis and I
was,
it was,
the room was unbelievable where you
going there and squirting a cup.
I was taking pictures and videos of this
room because it's like you can't imagine
what's going on in there,
but I want to wait until Ila sitting
across from me so she can,
you need to see her reaction to this.
So there's a lot of stuff I want to talk
about,
but I want to close up the show with
Roseanne.
You guys have heard about Roseanne,
the situation of her calling.
I don't remember if this lady,
she said she looked like a monkey.
Shar show got canceled.
So she's finally issued an explanation.
She's finally issued a statement,
an apology of sorts that I think clears
everything up.
And I think you guys will all agree.
So in her own words.
Hello?
Hello.
Is it loud enough out there,
Dan?
I don't want to hear.
Yeah,
no,
it's fine.
Cause it only she's Mike.
Everybody else is just getting ambient.
So once she starts talking and listen.
All right.
I get frustrated with Dan.
We have sound issues and I yell at Dan,
you guys have any sound issues with the
unbalanced or itchy weird shit?
Emailed Dan and give him,
give him hell.
Okay.
Sounds good.
We don't have chat anymore,
so we don't even know for fucking up
anymore.
By the way,
this figurine and another video,
she explains that this is a statue of
her body.
Oh,
maybe skippy's into that.
Maybe.
Maybe d Roseanne would be,
that kind of surprises me that skippy
wants to fuck oprah does.
I know the figurine with your mouse.
I just took it full screen right here.
Yeah,
there she is.
Does it surprise you that skippy wants
to fuck oprah?
I mean that's kind of cool.
He's like,
Damn,
you know what?
I want to fucking,
you know who I want around third base on
Oprah.
I wonder what's very surprised when he
said that.
What base is ass play?
Cause that then that's the dugout.
The metaphor kind of breaks down cause
it's like ask plays almost more advanced
than a home run in a way.
In most circles.
Anyway.
So I wonder if skippy's ever fingered an
asshole.
I don't wonder that.
Why do I hear him talking in the
background?
I was that Ian,
that must be in through your mic.
All right,
look at Sarah's info.
Okay.
All right.
Well anyway,
as digression in her own words,
here's Roseanne explaining.
Okay.
How's it sound?
I don't know.
Hello.
Hello?
Hello,
hello,
hello.
Okay.
And you said I'm in three outfits or
niche.
Here's the problem,
like imagine,
are you filming?
Yes.
Imagine a presidential address.
Like you're busted with a killing a
hooker,
like just no hear me out.
And they say tonight the president is
going to give his address and then the
camera fades out and it's fucking the
president on his desk in the Oval
Office.
And he's like,
I do not have sex with that hooker.
Right.
Um,
imagine in his statement the keep and
save his job.
There were jump cuts,
multiple outfits,
difference.
I'm trying to talk about,
you've told me this $300.
Do you know that?
That's what my tweet was about.
I know you've explained this literally
was why I thought the bridge was why.
So that clears it up.
Wow.
So there's like,
there's a lot of interesting things here
about this field.
First of all,
this is on her,
this is on her official youtube channel.
This was uploaded by her,
her directly deliver on the Dan Barker
Channel.
Let's see.
Anyway,
this is probably my favorite clip to
come out of this whole possibly year
2018 this might be the strongest clip of
the whole year.
Roseanne,
what do you have to say in your defense
job?
There were jump cuts.
You've told me this 300 times.
What is wrong with her?
She's like,
I don't think she's on drugs,
but like my God,
she's like breaking down just like
Christ.
He doesn't look good.
This was posted this this previous week,
right?
This is very recent.
You think it was recorded recently or
was this right after the incident?
No,
no,
no.
This is,
maybe this is,
this is after some thoughtful after some
reflection,
but like the question is,
well here after some after,
I love this.
This is so good.
After some careful consideration and
some thoughtful reflection,
Rosanne has decided to issue a statement
on her controversial tweets.
That's what my point was about.
I know you've explained this.
Literally.
That was why I thought the bridge was
why.
Now I've got an interesting question for
you.
Do you think this in a way,
does this help her?
No.
Okay.
Why?
Almost?
I'm more inclined to believe her because
she's like,
she's very passionate about,
she's very passionate about it or I'm,
I'm somewhat inclined to believe that,
um,
that it,
it wasn't necessarily coming from a
place of,
he's done
prove that statement.
That's a strong statement.
However,
I'm also inclined to believe that she's
a fucking psycho.
What makes you think that?
What makes you say at all,
Dan?
Dan,
I don't know.
Just something,
something,
something about,
well,
and she goes about it.
I don't know.
Anyway,
guys,
um,
you know,
I just thought that there's really a lot
of value here.
I thought this was a great clip and I
thought,
well,
let me,
let me draft this in a,
in another way.
Why?
And for those reasons,
amount.
I've been waiting,
I do that for a long time.
I got this soundbite here is I have
another one.
The angels in heaven.
Oh,
I think the curb ones better.
Why?
I love that soundboard.
Oh,
you're a conductor,
dude.
I feel like,
I feel like a Dj for the first time.
Yeah.
But here actually,
this is fine.
This is like right when they start
rolling.
That was like her off the cuff thing.
Have you ever seen someone famous so
unhinged in your life?
I think it,
what's so fascinating about it?
I thought that bitch was,
why
does that,
whoa.
All right.
It's crazy to see anybody that unhinged,
but it does kind of give you an insight
to how,
how fucked up he is kind of in a way.
It's like Whoa,
probably shouldn't have been working on
that show to begin with,
you know?
Yeah.
That's where you're at mentally.
You know what I'm saying?
I thought that was wow.
It was why
God damn fucking open a portal.
That shit.
It's kind of what that is,
isn't it?
Um,
but so then take too,
she gets her shit together by the way.
What the fuck are they put that on our
official channel,
man,
I just loved that so much.
So this is her actual,
you know,
real statement on it
bar.
And I'd like to welcome you to my own
studio,
to my fellow and sister Americans
without the filter of the biased media.
That's my statement from the very
beginning.
And it will continue to be one abc
called and asked me to explain my gray,
just an unforgettable tweet.
I told them I thought Valerie Jarrett
was white and I'm willing to go on the
BW,
Jimmy Kimmel or whatever other show you
want me to go on to my audience.
Now what happened with about 40 minutes
after that,
my show was canceled before even one
advertiser pulled out and I was labeled
a racist.
Why you ask?
Well,
the answer is simple.
It's because I voted for Donald Trump
and that is not allowed in Hollywood.
Pretty Shitty.
Well,
okay,
so ma'am,
well first of all wasn't the whole
premise of the show that she was like a
trump voter and like so clearly,
obviously not that they get away,
they gave you the show because you were
a trump supporter because they thought
it was an interesting dynamic.
Right.
So that doesn't make sense.
Although I do,
I actually do believe that she thought
she was white because I've seen a
picture and the lady doesn't,
she my first guest wouldn't be black.
And I mean if you can elicit,
yeah,
this response was,
why?
That's,
but at any rate,
she's,
I don't know if let's say,
let's say if she did think she was
white,
then is the tweet and like,
how bad is the tweet still?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
obviously it doesn't have the whole
connotation of calling a black person a
monkey that everyone thought it did.
So it's not as bad.
Like the context does help,
but it's still,
she's unhinged it,
she,
she was probably on thin ice already at
the end of the executives at ABC because
she'd just nonstop was ranting on
twitter about it.
Okay.
Nine Times.
Right.
And can you imagine working with that?
I mean,
I'm sure that's not an isolated
incident.
Yeah.
I actually,
I think what happened,
I'm like you said,
it's probably that they were like,
all right,
like,
enough,
this is Nikki.
Yeah.
This,
this is not going to get better.
But see,
I mean,
just to kind of line that up in a way,
how did you,
MMM,
here's a clip again,
this is all on our personal youtube
channel,
which is just so fascinating to me.
But,
um,
here,
here's a little soundbite they uploaded
right before they started shooting the
first season of her new
shut.
How did you,
you're so fucking tired.
How did you do this for 10 years?
Are you shitting me?
I lost my fucking mind.
I lost my marriage.
I had locked my phone.
The kids drop our marriage and get wad
and a fucking half and one bro.
The fuck do you think both at the
hospitalized for four different nervous
breakdown?
That's how I did it.
Thanks for asking.
That's actually great.
It's pretty wild,
man.
She's a fucking character.
You know what,
Rosanne,
she's such a,
I thought that was why.
I Dunno.
It's so hard to say,
you know,
with the,
sorry to say,
but either way,
we've got this wonderful sound bite that
I think will truly live in infamy.
I don't see this going anywhere off my
soundboard for a while.
That was why
so good.
Um,
like I said,
let's see what else we've got here.
We've got a,
we've got all this stuff.
We've got some great shit.
I'm gonna save this though.
We've got the news.
We should just hit the news if the news,
but before we do hit the news,
we're going to bring back the news by
the way,
but before we do,
hi.
All right.
Maybe it's just me having fun.
There's a possibility that there's
thousands of people watching right now
and saying,
please stop fucking doing that.
I'm having a great time though.
All right,
Dan,
give us the news.
All right.
Hit Him with the Stinger.
Oh God.
All right,
let's do the news.
Everybody.
You got to flip your TV.
It's rather a input by the way,
so you can follow along.
Right?
Right.
All right,
so,
um,
top story today,
come into us from a CNBC here.
Um,
I'm sure,
uh,
a lot of people heard about this
facebook at work pc,
or is it hd?
Mine?
Itchy my too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hello.
It's fucking,
oh my God.
There you go.
All right.
Hey.
So,
uh,
yeah,
top store.
We got a facebook loses $100 billion
plus in market cap.
Wow.
This past week,
uh,
their shares plunged a on Thursday,
or I guess it was Wednesday after hours,
uh,
by 20%,
um,
which it was in response to them
announcing that they're,
they're going to up their spending on
privacy concerns and fighting fake news
on the platform.
People were like,
fuck that.
I want that rush of money rights.
Um,
and I,
I guess it,
it,
it basically is more so about they're
going to be spending a ton of money to
do this.
Um,
and that kind of coupled with the fact
that I guess their user growth has
really slowed down.
Surprise,
surprise.
Facebook fucking sucks.
Nobody wants to sign up anymore.
And so it's just kind of created this
perfect storm where,
yeah,
in a single night,
$100 billion disappeared off the market.
Single biggest loss for a company.
Right?
The single biggest loss.
However,
um,
and just to give some perspective number
two,
uh,
I looked this up on September 22nd the
year 2000 Intel lost 90 billion,
so about 18 years ago.
And that was,
you know,
the.com
crash.
That happened at the end of the
nineties.
Well,
sort of results.
What I'd like to say is suck my Dick
facebook.
Fuck you,
mark Zuckerberg.
Fuck you.
Facebook.
I cannot wait for facebook to become the
next my space.
I'm very,
I've said this all the time,
but I hate everything about facebook and
I'm so fucking glad.
By the way I read a report,
they're like their earnings from them
stealing content from where everywhere
else on the internet,
like the earnings aren't good and the
engagement isn't good.
And all I have to say is for those
reasons I'm out.
Fuck you,
facebook.
I am so glad to see that website die.
Well,
maybe don't get too excited yet because
apparently they were up 20% this year,
so they're basically just back to where
they were a few months ago.
Well,
let's see it.
Let's,
let's wash his baby slide.
Yeah,
we'll see what happens.
What else you got in the news,
Dan?
All right,
so next up,
um,
uh,
Papa John.
Oh No,
Um,
we talked about this a couple of weeks
ago or last week and not,
not having a great month.
I'm having a great July.
Um,
Papa John,
the man is now suing Papa John the
company.
Um,
no,
he's going after him.
John Shatner civil war and it's the
civil war.
It's the pizza wars and I'm,
no,
the pizza wars are upon us.
When Papa John Fights Papa John,
you know who wins?
Nobody.
Little seizures.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Oh,
I love this description.
Shatner has admitted to,
as he said,
the n word on a conference call with a
marketing firm.
Shatner claimed the firm asked if he was
racist.
Listen,
are you racist then use the n word
inscribing house KFC is Colonel Sanders
used to talk chat and has since also
said that he told the firm that he
himself wouldn't ever use that word
after having used the word right.
Which is kind of the confusing part of
this whole thing is he's like
acknowledging that he said it,
but also denying that he said it in the
Sweden.
I've always,
when I,
when I saw that headline and then I read
the article,
I was like,
well again,
I do think there needs to be a disc.
Like I haven't,
we all fucking kind of lost our minds a
little bit.
I mean,
he shouldn't have said it.
That's for sure.
If a marketing company asks,
are you racist?
Don't drop the n bomb this show how not
racist you are.
Which is basically what he did.
But like he didn't like use the,
he didn't weaponize the word,
he didn't use the word he was talking
about the word.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like the headlines Bra,
the drug drops to Ed on the conference
call and you're like,
whoa.
Like he just like called someone the n
word or somewhat not exactly what
happened,
but I mean,
you know,
Papa John,
he's sliding that guy spent,
he spent way too much time close to a
pizza oven.
His face is like melting off like that
Mozzarella cheese is like,
it's in the pores and men that pizza is
ready to,
you can't that pizza
that peet's has been baked too may time.
So,
yeah,
so he's going after them,
uh,
saying that,
you know,
he was unfairly forced out as the,
uh,
head and I guess he's,
I thought he was out completely.
I guess it was just that he was forced
out as the chairman.
He still owns 29% of the company while
he was on the board of directors and
then they booted him.
Right.
And so he,
he's still got his,
his claws in it a little bit.
Um,
but they're,
they're trying real hard to get rid of
him.
I love his papa John who is the man.
You mean pop a boner
and usurp power.
You've got that meme.
I saw this man,
man.
I really think the y'all,
yeah,
this kind of says it all.
You can't trust anybody.
Even yourself.
What happens when Papa John Tries to
execute?
Papa John's thought provoking.
Really.
It Dan,
what's next?
Some deep stuff.
All right.
Uh,
let's see.
What is next.
Oh,
this is really cool.
Um,
so this week a,
a team of Italian researchers announced
that after analyzing some data for the
last two years,
they are saying with a high degree of
confidence that they have discovered a
lake of water on Mars.
Um,
it is under the southern polar cap.
And I guess this is very similar.
Um,
the reason they knew to look for this
specific thing is,
um,
there's these kinds of lakes in an class
here on earth in a very similar fashion.
And so they were using,
there's this European,
a space mission called the Mars Express
orbiter that was able to use ground
penetrating radar and they detected a
what looked like a lake,
but they weren't sure.
Um,
but again,
after a analyzing this for the last two
years,
they with a high degree of confidence
are able to say this is a wow 20
kilometer wide lake sitting,
uh,
an amateur and a half under the ice cap.
Any estimate when we can get anything up
there to do some digging?
Yeah.
So I mean that's the problem.
It's,
it's,
that's still a ways off,
uh,
just because of the weight of all the
equipment you would need.
I mean,
you need a drill that can go almost a
mile straight,
thrilling when we can cut into that ice.
Like if they find like there's two
options or there's three options,
really.
One option is that they find life that
is identical and DNA to ours,
which could mean that life originated on
Mars.
Right.
And then like a meteor impact or
something she sperm did onto earth.
And then the second option is that it's
different.
Completely different.
The third options,
there's nothing there.
They're all fascinating and their own
right.
The craziest one for me would be like,
if it's completely a different origin of
life,
sure.
But if you do find life,
I feel like the most likely would be
that it's the same Dna,
I feel like.
Yeah.
And I think you're though that if it
were completely different from life on
earth,
that that won't be the coolest thing
because that just shows.
Okay.
So it developed completely independently
on two planets in the solar system.
That means it's everywhere.
How much you'd like to see.
Another alien life form that has a
completely different building blocks
would be late discovery of,
of the life.
I can,
I cannot wait for that.
That's so cool.
God bless.
Really awesome.
Really awesome stuff.
So good job.
Good job.
Italy.
[inaudible] killing it over there.
Uh,
next up.
so I don't know if everybody,
I'm sure everybody's heard about this.
So James Gunn got fired from,
uh,
the guardians of the galaxy three.
Um,
because,
uh,
some old tweets got dug up from about 10
years ago of him making some pretty,
pretty distasteful.
What was,
what was the joke you have if you have
an example?
So I have one example.
Uh,
and in the words of the article,
this is from entertainment weekly.
Uh,
this was one of the only ones that could
reprint.
So I can only imagine the rest were
pretty bad too.
This one,
uh,
was laughter is the best medicine.
That's why I laugh at people with AIDS.
Oh,
fucking cares.
That's not that.
You know,
seriously.
Yeah.
Yep.
Now they did say this again.
This is potentially one of the least
find,
find the worst one.
They've all been,
they've all been scrubbed at this.
Come on.
They're out there on that.
I'm sure they're out there.
They're out there.
Um,
and fine.
Let's,
let's see.
You know,
that's not bad.
Let's see what's,
yeah,
I mean,
that's,
that's not the worst,
but here's the whole,
you know,
you're looking in switching the,
uh,
the computer.
Fuck,
he's in the hot seat right here though.
You can find them.
I'm googling it was on it.
Okay.
Um,
so basically what this all is,
is,
uh,
you know,
James Gunn,
he's pretty outspoken critic of trump
and,
um,
some this right wing group that didn't
like that he was talking all this shit,
uh,
decided to kind of troll through all of
his old tweets and everything.
And yeah,
I mean,
I guess James Gunn has been on twitter
forever,
and so there was thousands and thousands
of these things and James Gunn,
if anybody knows anything about James
Gunn,
he,
he's an edgy dude like that.
Everything before doing the guardians of
the galaxy movies that he's ever done
was pretty Raunchy.
What's the,
uh,
what's the headline?
So the headline is there's a campaign to
get him,
um,
to get him rehired that it was bullshit
that they fired him.
And,
and you know the fans,
they,
they love the guardians movies.
They think he's done a good job.
They don't care and they want them back
end.
Um,
as of yesterday,
300,000
signatures in a matter of,
I think two or three days.
So Disney's,
that's like,
you have found a,
Oh yeah,
let's hear it.
Give me more.
Give me the most cause that,
that wouldn't have got him fired.
All right,
so here's an I like when little boys
touch me in my silly place.
Another thing that's pretty cringy.
I mean,
that's the thing.
None of these are even really that sexy.
It's really not funny at all.
The best thing about being raped is when
you're done being raped and it's like,
whew,
this feels great not being raped.
God,
can you imagine tweeting that?
It's like so embarrassing.
Well,
and he's embarrassed.
I mean,
he said like,
I was an idiot.
I was just trying to be edgy.
I'm not this person anymore.
10 years.
Think back 10 years ago,
how much like of a person you can
change.
I mean,
the weird thing is like Disney hired
this guy who has a reputation and now
all the sudden they're shocked what
James Gunn,
this whole thing of firing someone for a
tweet they may 10 years ago.
So obscene.
And I,
and I think Disney now,
it's probably like,
maybe we were,
I don't know if they're regretting it,
but I don't think,
I don't think a trillion signatures will
ever make Disney eat attack.
They'll never change their mind.
No.
And that's,
I doubt it too.
Um,
even if they got triple those,
what else?
Do you have any other tweets?
I actually enjoy,
there's a bunch of your,
what he says.
So,
um,
oh,
there's a maid's typical comments about
nine 11.
It's a holocaust.
Um,
just grabbed a monkey masturbating on a
young child and it was called Terry that
made him extremely happy.
Uh,
it looks like those were the only ones
that they tweeted.
And then we'll just given kind of some
more examples of the type of thing.
But again,
that's,
that's what's great.
Disney will not rehire him because you
know,
this is Disney and they haven't been
clean,
but why did they hire him in the first
place then everybody like,
did they not know who he was?
Companies are such fucking policies
these days.
Like,
like the minute they sniff controversy.
Yeah.
It's like everybody shut the fucking
door.
You know what I mean?
You know what I'm saying?
Listen,
this goes out to every company out there
to stick it about firing someone because
they did something offensive.
I mean,
come on.
Technically the same company,
she got fired by ABC,
which is Disney.
Disney owns everything.
Disney.
Disney owns like the butt plug that you
see and they have a butt plug brand.
Do they?
Yeah.
They own everything.
I don't know why you said Bob Plug,
but like they own Disney owns
everything.
Didn't they just buy out a huge company?
Well,
they're buying Fox.
They're trying to and it looks like it's
happening.
There was a little bit of a back and
forth.
They were in a bidding war,
but there they're going to win his,
they're plucking Disney.
Disney.
When they own every company in America,
that's when,
that's when fascism will be here.
Cause you're not gonna be able to make
any jokes at all.
And then you,
you,
you work in a factory.
All of a sudden they own like
fulfillment factories and you can't joke
about the holocaust anymore suddenly.
Oh,
6 million,
shut it down.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
I do.
For the record,
think those numbers are accurate or
you're not a holocaust.
But I will say that nine 11 is highly
suspicious.
And let me tell you,
there's nothing I love more than
monkeys.
Jerk.
That one's a weird one that he would
tweet out.
I like monkeys jerking on kids.
That's how fucking weird image dog that
I don't mind.
Let's move on.
All right.
It's the next,
uh,
next step.
This is a article from enemy.
I thought this was interesting.
Their enemy.
Uh,
it's a British,
um,
entertainment magazine.
Uh,
there are seven Robin Hood movies being
made.
Robin Hood Movie.
Well,
no,
that already got made.
That's the,
uh,
yeah.
Ridley Scott,
I believe.
Oh,
is that a good movie?
No.
Okay.
That's probably why you haven't heard of
it.
It's not good at all.
That's a shame.
So that's an older one.
Um,
but yeah,
they are a in this era of reboots and
relaunches and restarts and all the
reasons you said seven,
seven,
did they not get the memo that like
everyone else was making it?
Robin had movie.
Yeah,
that's a good question.
I mean they all have kind of their own
take on it to be fair.
Um,
but does anybody even give a shit about
Robin Hood?
Like I like Robin Hood.
Excuse me,
Dan.
Okay.
I like Robin Hood.
You're the target audience.
Well guess what?
You're going to be thrilled to hear.
You want to be busy this fall.
So just to quickly just rattled them
off.
We've got a movie called uh,
Robin Hood origins,
uh,
or it was called Robin Hood origins.
It's since been robin.
Dan,
I'm going to stop you.
I don't need seven.
Robin had titles.
Okay.
All right.
Fair enough.
Look them up yourself,
everybody,
if you're,
if you're curious.
I sense I sense this.
Yeah,
that's a lot of Robin Hood.
It's a lot of Robin Hood.
To be fair.
There's a lot of rabbinic.
All right,
next story.
Um,
this is actually like two weeks ago.
This is too good.
I mean,
we had to,
uh,
had to do it to them,
had to do it to him.
There was a flight in China that loss
pressure and dropped 20,000
feet.
Um,
because the pilots were vaping in the
cockpit.
How does that happen?
What's the correlation?
So they were vaping and it got so full
or hotboxing the,
they were hot boxing the cockpit.
Wow.
Yes.
And,
and it got,
and basically they didn't want the vapor
to escape into the passenger cabin,
give away the fact that they were doing
this.
So,
uh,
the copilot tried to flip a switch that
would keep the air from cycling into the
rest of the cabin,
uh,
and hit the wrong button,
which depressurized the cabinet.
Why is there a button to depressurize
the cabin?
Midflight anyway,
that seems like a little danger.
That's a good question.
I mean maybe there's some preventative
thing that they need to do that
occasionally for,
but um,
but yeah,
I guess it was right next to the other
switch and it was so,
so much fucking Dank vape smoke in there
that they,
uh,
hit the wrong button and just had to
kind of barrel down all the oxygen mask
drops and uh,
yeah,
so maybe nation,
the air over in China,
are they executed when they land in
China?
I mean,
uh,
it is China.
So let's just say that.
Um,
nobody's heard from these vape natures.
I hope wherever you are,
you're vaping in heaven now,
but everyone's okay.
God blessed Hallelujah injuries.
Uh,
our last,
uh,
this is actually the last story here.
Um,
a Colombian,
a drug dog has been moved into witness
protection for lack of a better term,
after a gang in Columbia put a hit on
this dog.
The dog named Sombra,
uh,
which means shadow in English,
which snipped out a record amount of
drugs in her career,
um,
has been forced to be moved to ensure
her safety is,
she's this dog has smoked,
smoked out,
sniffed out 5.3
tons of cocaine to that though was
fucking awesome.
Yup.
There,
although it says here the hit is only
70,000.
They're going to I think,
feel like,
yeah.
Which is a,
by the way,
200 million a Colombian pesos.
Yeah,
but you were just calling it costs like
a million pesos for like a loaf of
bread.
Well,
yeah.
And just to put it into some
perspective,
in 2012,
there was a whole incident where the
gang had put down a hits on police
officer's offering $500.
Whoa.
So,
so by comparison,
this dog is the dog.
The dog,
Columbia are murdering people for five
police for $500.
Well,
uh,
the article about it says that they
found leaflets signed by the gang
offering $500.
I don't know if anybody actually took
them up.
Broke ass gang.
500 broke because of this dog fucking
busting all their coke,
so that's sad is how that's,
come on guys.
It's a fucking dog.
He can kill people.
You can kill helpless civilians,
but spare the dog.
The dog's out of it people.
Come on.
All right,
so there is this,
this is sombra little hero right here.
I hope I pray for him.
So that's it.
That's it.
That's the news.
That's the hard right there guys.
That's everything that's out there.
Yup.
Oh No.
There's a couple of things I want to do
first before we go out.
First of all,
why the fuck did I want to bring Ian
Out?
I don't remember.
Oh,
oh God.
I wanted to make and smell the belly
button lint.
I feel like I missed the train though,
but it is Dan's birthday recently and we
want it to honor Dan for his birthday.
Damn.
Would you come join us here for a
minute?
All right,
hold on.
I wish I could bring in out too,
but we don't have enough people here and
I'm going to make,
I want to make you sniff this.
It's a,
it's a rite of passage that everyone in
this crew needs to abide by.
So Dan,
it is your birthday.
You do mean a lot to us here at the
[inaudible] podcast.
Thank you.
We want to,
uh,
we really want to honor honor that,
that a day.
Well,
what's your age?
31 31.
Yeah.
Big One,
right?
Well,
here you go,
dude.
Please go.
Enjoy.
Read it.
You can open it up.
Yeah.
Open it up.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Let's see what we got
working on it,
man.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Today you are a bar Mitzvah.
Hold this up so we can see this last
part here.
You're also handsome,
fun,
good natured.
Oh,
this.
we're going on a journey.
Yes sir.
Okay.
Kind,
smart and caring.
Yup.
You're a mench and a blessing in so many
ways.
What more could any family asked for us?
So proud of you?
Dan would leave.
What did you get?
Mazal Tov and lots of love and a gift
card.
The hot topic.
Everybody.
How much for all these shit?
15 bucks.
The bare minimum.
That's any amount between 15 and 500.
I want you to spend that and I want to
know what you buy.
There are still hot topics.
Yeah,
they're out there actually that we did
it.
We listen,
we are very generous.
Heard the HD podcasts.
We did get you this.
Oh,
it is a constellation.
But the real gift is the hot topic.
I appreciate that.
Now this is kind of garbage honestly.
Yeah.
Throw that out all about the hot topic.
But um,
I do want you to go to hot topic and
report back on what you were able to buy
for 15 or 15 bucks.
No,
it's going to happen.
You're going to end up going there and
spending because you can't buy anything
for 15 bucks.
Kind of cursing.
You,
cursing me to,
uh,
you're going to,
next time you see me,
I'm going to have um,
a bunch of,
uh,
invader Zim shirts.
I love it.
Uh,
um,
congratulations.
Come here.
You guys switched really fast.
All right.
Happy Birthday Dude.
We're doing that.
But I did give him a real gift you guys
into that,
but whatever.
Oh God.
Oh,
what a slip that Ian come in here.
And finally guys to close out the show
next week.
Remember Tuesday Isla returns episode
Thursday Dunky and Leah episode.
We've got a lot on deck in.
This is a big moment for you to talk
about a bar Mitzvah.
This is when you become a man.
This is when you become initiated.
And two are little clan here,
right?
So in,
are you ready to give,
this is skippy's belly button lint
collection.
Stay awake during the meeting pills.
What the fuck has he been eating?
I was looking at that too.
It's one to two for regular meetings.
Two to four,
four ward conferences.
Eight to 10 for dry high council night.
The fuck are they feeding him?
What the fuck?
This is like Mormon medicine.
I think it's candy cause uh,
it says one 79 cents.
Well that's a little strange.
I have to say regardless,
he in go ahead and have to,
I really,
I don't know.
You don't have to do anything you don't
want to again,
but now I kind of weirdly want to,
cause you want to be one of us.
I guess.
Yeah,
I guess I'll do it.
I guess I'll smell it.
Okay.
Give it a strong with,
okay.
Wow.
That was a strong one.
It's got a hokey describe.
Okay.
Maybe I'm detecting pomegranate,
right?
I don't know.
It smells like an old mattress,
like a really old man,
like,
like you as you're walking down the
street and they see that and you see it,
see it on the side of the road.
To me it's so much worse than that.
Like there's such a must.
It's on the leave of worse than a street
mattress,
bro.
It's like a,
it's like a street mattress.
Black Hole.
Like there was consolidated until like a
marble of its smell.
You know what I mean?
They like compressed.
There's like little pubic hairs in it.
Oh,
that's great.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
we're going to wrap this and fucking
blaze it someday and I want you to be
the first one to hit it.
I don't,
and I was thinking
maybe it's a regenerative thing.
Maybe it's got power.
Like,
yeah,
you want to try it.
Do you want to eat something?
I don't want to eat it out.
Bye.
Yeah,
I love being here.
We love Dan the birthday boy.
Shout out to Isla,
who's back.
Shut off to Sarah,
who played valliant Lee and won.
And of course the real mvp.
Hi Sam,
whom we all love.
And of course the press,
the inheritor Bosun in the house.
Papa John's out
close in the house,
phone the house.
But that being said,
guys,
well thank you so much for watching.
We'll see you on Tuesday,
Thursday.
Why don't you guys have a great,
great weekend and I wish you all the
very,
very best that you can cut it down.
You can go out.
Yeah.